on direct de pau bonsoir françois bayrou
la prochaine étape marquante du
feuilleton grec était la sortie du
paysannat zone euro bonsoir c'est en
tout cas le risque que tout le monde
court je vis tout le monde parce que je
ne crois pas que un accident arrivait à
la grèce concernent seulement les grecs
je pense que si l'accident qui paraît
inscrits dans le nom référendum c'est à
dire la sortie de l'euro la rupture de
la zone euro se produit alors les grecs
paieront évidemment un prix très
important mais le reste de l'europe
aussi parce que nous sommes une maison
et si une des pièces de la maison se
trouve envahi où se trouve incendiés
alors le reste de la maison court aussi
de grands risques
comment se sent l'européen convaincu que
vous êtes depuis hier soir
ommm je vois bien depuis longtemps que
les peuples ont de vente eu des
représentations qui sont des promesses
c'est que ces promesses sont séduisantes
et que beaucoup sont profondément
sincère en pensant que on va pouvoir
inventer une autre europe
pour ma part je crois que ce sont assez
largement des illusions et que ce qu'on
va vivre maintenant c'est une question
très simple
c est ce que on a pu grâce à tout ce qui
s'est passé ou à cause de tout ce qui
s'est passé
retrouvez davantage de confiance pour la
grèce alors ça marchera mieux
ou est-ce qu'on a moins de confiance
plus de perturbations plus d'incertitude
alors la situation deviendra pires que
je crois que c'est que depuis des mois
et des mois à force de manoeuvre on est
dans une situation qui va être une
situation de plus grande incertitude
pour les peuples et notamment pour le
peuple grec
deux trois propositions très concrètes
que selon vous alexis tsipras ce devrait
proposer à demain au sommet de leur
groupe
vous savez la campagne a été fait sur le
thème de l'austérité nous ne voulons
plus de l'austérité mais la question qui
se pose pour les grecs comme pour bien
d'autres peuples et jeudi à me voir
comme pour le peuple français
cette question elle est simple lorsque
vous avez besoin d'emprunter tous les
jours pour payer vos salaires et vos
retraites alors la seule question qui se
pose c'est que c'est de savoir si vos
prêteurs ont confiance en vous ou pas
s'ils peuvent vous prêter avec un
sentiment de sécurité auquel cas les
taux sont bas ou si au contraire ils ont
l'impression que vous risquez de ne pas
rembourser le prêt que vous contracté
auprès d'eux
auquel cas les taux d'intérêt explosent
et d'ailleurs vous ne trouvez plus
personne pour vous prêter c'est
aujourd'hui cela la situation de la
grèce et le et le procès qui est fait à
l'europe
en réalité est mal placée alors je sais
très bien le de quel romantisme
beaucoup sont animées je ne prétends pas
qu'il manque de sincérité
ce que je crois c'est que la situation
faite aujourd'hui à la grèce va mettre
demain davantage en péril ce avant que
son économie qu'ils ne pourront plus
sortir de l'argent pour faire les
importations nécessaires au commerce ou
au tourisme et que simplement les
banques grecques ne sont pas sûrs de
pouvoir ré ouvrir et tout cela c'est le
c'est le résultat d'un mécanisme
d'incertitude et de soupçons qui paraît
très difficile à arrêter je souhaiterais
qu'il s'arrête
françois bayrou souhaiterait que les
conversations débouche sur du positif
j'en doute un peu françois bayrou sur le
plan politique le procès qui est fait à
l'europe pour reprendre
vos mots justifié ou pas ne nous
mène-t-il pas vers un renforcement des
formations d'extrême droite partout en
europe
bon je ne ne crois pas ça parce que là
on fait des analyses qui sont d analyse
électorale c'est pas ça la question si
vous me permettez de vous le dire
la question c'est que des familles
entières des millions de familles et des
entreprises entières des centaines de
milliers d'entreprises sont aujourd'hui
sur le point de rencontrer le pire des
accidents économiques qu'elles puissent
rencontrer et je voudrais beaucoup que
angela merkel françois hollande qui tout
à l'heure vont s'exprimer
j'espère dans le même sens trouve une
solution pour cela je ne je ne je ne
crois pas cette solution facile je ne
crois pas qu'il soit probable comme on
l'a dit que la grèce s'était renforcée
par le référendum d'hier je crois au
contraire que la situation est plus
difficile encore à traiter qu'elle
l'aurait été s'il y avait eu un oui le
ça n'aurait pas été facile mais ça
aurait été plus facile que la situation
d'aujourd'hui
pensez vous que angela merkel justement
que vous évoquiez un instant soit prête
à abandonner la ligne dure et je
en vérité je ne sais pas très bien ce
que veut dire le mot ligne dure au fond
la grèce et le reste de l'europe ont
besoin de deux choses
ils ont besoin d'une part de rétablir un
sentiment de confiance dans les prés que
se font les pays entre eux parce que si
a pas de confiance sera pas de près et
donc ils ont besoin de rétablir l'idée
que oui on va pouvoir à terme s'en
sortir et rembourser une partie
importante de la dette et 2
la question c'est comment rétablir
l'économie grecque comment peut-on à
nouveau produire produire des richesses
alors que vous le savez l'économie de la
grèce s'est effondrée depuis six mois
comment fait-on et ça ça n'est pas une
ligne
demandez de la sécurité dans les
relations entre pays c'est pas une ligne
dure
c'est contre c'est au contraire la ligne
la plus réaliste qu'on puisse trouver
c'est une présentation fausse que de
faire croire qu'il ya d'un côté des
méchants qui exigerait des positions
intenables et de l'autre des gentils
qu'ils seraient là pour aider les
peuples se c'est une position fausses
merci pour ces formations qu'on
entretient merci françois